Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. To protect the identity of certain witnesses, some names in this episode have been changed. The notorious 18th Street Gang was one of Los Angeles' largest criminal gangs, boasting up to 50,000 members across the United States, and an alliance with La AME, a US-based criminal organisation also known as the Mexican Mafia.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用程序或我们网站上的本集节目简介。为了保护某些目击者的身份，本集中的一些姓名已被更改。臭名昭著的第18街帮是洛杉矶最大的犯罪帮派之一，在美国各地拥有多达5万名成员，并与La AME（一个也称为墨西哥手推车的美国犯罪组织）结成了同盟。
In the early 1980s, a rebellious group broke away from 18th Street and formed the Vineland Boys, named after Vineland Street in North Hollywood where some of the crew played football. Dead affection was considered a betrayal by the 18th Street Gang, resulting in a deadly decades-long conflict between the two groups. In the 1980s and 90s, LA Street Gangs with Latin American origins were expected to comply with conduct laid down and enforced by La AME. They were also required to pay taxes to La AME to cement control over their turf and ensure the protection of incarcerated gang members.
在20世纪80年代初，一个叛逆的集团脱离了第18街帮，组成了瓦兰德男孩帮，以北好莱坞的瓦兰德街命名，一些成员曾在那里的街区踢足球。这种出走被第18街帮视为背叛，导致这两个集团之间爆发了长达数十年的致命冲突。在20世纪80年代和90年代，具有拉丁美洲血统的洛杉矶街头帮派被期望遵守La AME制定并执行的行为准则。他们还被要求向La AME缴纳税款，以巩固对自身地盘的控制，并确保对入狱帮派成员的保护。
When the Vineland Boys refused to pay their taxes, they were denounced by La AME, and in 1999 the group's founder was murdered by rival gangs. Following his death, several senior members, dubbed shock callers, controlled and regulated the gang's activities. In the early 2000s, the Vineland Boys attempted to smooth things over with La AME. During their efforts to ingratiate themselves back into the fold, they established a reputation for extreme violence and recklessness, with their members considered some of the most dangerous in the city.
当瓦兰德男孩帮拒绝纳税时，他们受到了La AME的谴责，1999年，该集团的创始人被敌对帮派谋杀。在他死后，几位被称为“震撼呼叫者”的高级成员控制并规范了该帮派的活动。在20世纪20年代初，瓦兰德男孩帮曾试图与La AME缓和关系。在他们试图重新博取信任的过程中，他们以极端暴力和鲁莽而闻名，其成员被认为是该市最危险的人员之一。
Unlike other gangs, the Vineland Boys didn't wear uniforms or identify themselves with a specific colour. Instead, they dressed as though they were businessmen. By 2002, the gang comprised mainly of Latin Americans who controlled much of the San Fernando Valley and Burbank drug trade and engaged in murder, narcotics trafficking, money laundering, racketeering and witness intimidation. The gang's leaders enforced harsh discipline among their members and associates, often assaulting or killing those who violated their organization's rules.
与其他帮派不同，瓦兰德男孩帮不穿制服，也不用特定的颜色来标明身份。相反，他们穿得像商人一样。到2002年，该帮派主要由拉丁美洲人组成，他们控制了圣费尔南多谷和伯班克的大部分毒品交易，并从事谋杀、贩毒、洗钱、敲诈勒索和恐吓证人等活动。帮派头目对成员和同伙实行严厉的纪律，经常殴打或杀害违反组织规则的人。
On Saturday, November 23, 2002, three members of the Vineland Boys were out driving after a birthday celebration at the graveside of a fallen member. Inebriated from consuming a mix of alcohol and drugs, the trio drove along Lancashire Boulevard in North Hollywood and came across 26-year-old Enrique Acosta sitting in his car. They decided to confront him, demanding to know where he was from. Enrique replied, Canoga Park, naming territory that belonged to a rival gang. In response, one of the Vineland Boys pulled out a 9mm handgun and shot him dead.
2002年11月23日，星期六，瓦兰德男孩帮的三名成员在为一名阵亡成员扫墓并举行生日庆祝活动后开车外出。三人因饮用酒精和毒品的混合物而神志不清，他们开车沿着北好莱坞的兰卡夏尔大道行驶，遇到了坐在车里的26岁青年恩里克·阿科斯塔。他们决定与他对峙，质问他是哪里人。恩里克回答说：“卡诺加公园”，说出了一个敌对帮派的地盘。作为回应，其中一名瓦兰德男孩帮成员掏出一把9毫米手枪，将其当场枪杀。
Four days later, in the early hours of Wednesday, November 27, 2002, 16-year-old Martha Puebla was lying in her bed in her home on the corner of Lowell Street and Case Avenue in Sun Valley, a neighborhood in the San Fernando Valley. Shortly before 2am, she heard a tapping sound at her ground floor window. Looking out, she saw her friend Sophia standing outside. Sophia wanted Martha to go out with her and her boyfriend, 18-year-old Christian Vargas, who was waiting in his car out front. As Martha deliberated whether or not to go, a man in a hooded sweatshirt approached Christian's
四天后，即2002年11月27日星期三清晨，16岁的玛莎·普埃布拉正躺在圣费尔南多谷一个街区太阳谷的洛厄尔街和凯斯大道交汇处的家中床上。凌晨2点前不久，她听到一楼窗户传来了敲击声。她往外看去，看到她的朋友索菲亚站在外面。索菲亚想让玛莎和她以及她的男友——18岁的克里斯蒂安·巴尔加斯一起出去，克里斯蒂安正坐在前方的车里等候。正当玛莎犹豫要不要去时，一个穿着连帽衫的男子走近了克里斯蒂安的
car. Suddenly, gunshots rang out, causing Sophia to leap through Martha's bedroom window to hide. When they were confident the gunmen had fled, Martha and Sophia went outside and cautiously approached the vehicle. Christian's body was riddled with bullets, but he was still alive. He begged the girls for help, but before assistance could arrive, he slumped forward against the steering wheel and died.
车。突然，枪声响起，吓得索菲亚跳进玛莎的卧室窗户躲藏。当他们确信枪手已经逃跑后，玛莎和索菲亚走到外面，小心翼翼地靠近车辆。克里斯蒂安的尸体布满了弹孔，但他还活着。他哀求女孩们救救他，但还没等救援赶到，他就向前瘫倒在方向盘上断了气。
Martha and Sophia appeared to be the only witnesses to the shooting of Christian Vargas. When police arrived at the scene, they separated the two young women, with homicide detectives Martin Pinner and Juan Rodriguez taking responsibility for the investigation. Sophia claimed that as soon as they heard the gunfire, Martha had cried out. It was Pepps. Pepps was the nickname of 19-year-old Jose Ledezma, Martha's ex-boyfriend, and a member of the Vineland Boys. Martha denied making this statement, telling the detectives that she hadn't seen the
玛莎和索菲亚似乎是枪杀克里斯蒂安·巴尔加斯的仅有目击者。警察到达现场后，将两名年轻女子分开，凶杀案侦探马丁·平纳和胡安·罗德里格斯负责调查。索菲亚声称，一听到枪声，玛莎就大喊了一声。那是“佩普斯”。“佩普斯”是19岁何塞·莱德斯马的绰号，他是玛莎的前男友，也是瓦兰德男孩帮的成员。玛莎否认说过这句话，她告诉侦探，她没有看到
gunmen and had merely speculated whether the assailant was one of the Vineland Boys. Aware that the gang sought vengeance against police informants, Martha remained cautious and offered little information to the investigators. Nevertheless, detectives Pinner and Rodriguez were familiar with the Vineland Boys and considered Jose Ledezma a strong lead. The 19-year-old was already wanted for questioning in relation to the murder of Enrique Acosta four days earlier, and bullet casings found that both crime scenes had been fired from a 9mm semi-automatic handgun.
枪手，只是猜测袭击者是否是瓦兰德男孩帮的成员。由于知道该帮派会对警方线人进行报复，玛莎保持着谨慎，只向调查人员透露了很少的信息。尽管如此，平纳和罗德里格斯侦探对瓦兰德男孩帮很熟悉，并将何塞·莱德斯马视为一条重要的线索。这名19岁的男子此前就因涉嫌四天前谋杀恩里克·阿科斯塔而被通缉，并且在两个犯罪现场发现的弹壳都是从一把9毫米半自动手枪中发射的。
A search of Ledezma's house was conducted that night. He wasn't home, but police found a loaded assault rifle hidden beneath a mattress, as well as letters from incarcerated members of the Vineland Boys. Police were told that Ledezma was currently with another Vineland member, 24-year-old Mario Catalan, who was also a suspect in Enrique Acosta's murder. When word reached Ledezma that police had searched his home, he, Catalan, and Catalan's girlfriend fled south across the border into Mexico in an attempt to gather funds for Ledezma's defense attorney.
当晚对莱德斯马的家进行了搜查。他不在家，但警察在床垫下发现了一支装满子弹的突击步枪，以及来自瓦兰德男孩帮入狱成员的信件。警方被告知，莱德斯马目前与另一名瓦兰德帮成员、24岁的马里奥·卡塔兰在一起，卡塔兰也是恩里克·阿科斯塔谋杀案的嫌疑人。当莱德斯马得知警方搜查了他的家时，他、卡塔兰以及卡塔兰的女友向南越过边境逃往墨西哥，试图为莱德斯马的辩护律师筹集资金。
Two days later, Mexican police were called to a dispute at a motel in the city of Tijuana, 129 miles south of LA. There, they found a heavily intoxicated Jose Ledezma, along with Mario Catalan, who was assaulting his girlfriend. She told the police that her two male companions were wanted for murder in the United States. A 9mm semi-automatic handgun was found in their vehicle, and Catalan had $3,200 in cash on him, which police believed he planned to use to bribe Mexican officials to protect him from extradition.
两天后，墨西哥警方接到报警，前往距离洛杉矶以南129英里的蒂华纳市的一家汽车旅馆处理纠纷。在那里，他们找到了喝得酩酊大醉的何塞·莱德斯马，以及正在殴打女友的马里奥·卡塔兰。她告诉警察，她的这两名男性同伴在美国被谋杀案通缉。在他们的车里发现了一把9毫米半自动手枪，卡塔兰身上带着3200美元现金，警方认为他打算用这些钱贿赂墨西哥官员以保护自己免于被引渡。
Both Ledezma and Catalan were immediately escorted back to Los Angeles and taken into custody. That night, detectives Pinar and Rod Regas interviewed Ledezma about the murders of Enrique Acosta and Christian Vargas. He didn't request a lawyer, instead giving flippant, profanity-laden answers while flatly denying any involvement. Certain he was the culprit, the detectives tried all their usual methods of interrogation, but LA gang members were loyal, tight-lipped, and notoriously hard to crack.
莱德斯马和卡塔兰立即被押送回洛杉矶并拘留。当晚，平纳和罗德里格斯侦探就恩里克·阿科斯塔和克里斯蒂安·巴尔加斯的谋杀案对莱德斯马进行了讯问。他没有要求请律师，而是给出轻率、充满脏话的回答，同时全盘否认任何参与。侦探们确信他就是罪魁祸首，于是尝试了所有常用的审讯方法，但洛杉矶的帮派成员忠诚、口风紧，而且出了名地难以攻克。
Ledezma simply insisted, You got the wrong person, buddy. Detective Pinar told him they had multiple witnesses who were willing to testify that he had shot Christian Vargas. One was Ledezma's ex-girlfriend, Martha Puebla, who had told police that he had been on his way to visit her the night of the shooting. Ledezma maintained his innocence, claiming he didn't know anyone named Martha. Detective Pinar then produced what is known as a six-pack, a photographic line-up of six
莱德斯马只是坚称：“老兄，你抓错人了。”平纳侦探告诉他，他们有多名证人愿意作证说他枪杀了克里斯蒂安·巴尔加斯。其中一人是莱德斯马的前女友玛莎·普埃布拉，她曾告诉警方，枪击当晚他正赶往她家。莱德斯马坚称自己无罪，声称他不认识叫玛莎的人。平纳侦探随后出示了所谓的“六人照”，这是一组六张照片，照片上的人与他们的主要嫌疑人具有相似的特征。
individuals with similar features to their prime suspect. It is shown to witnesses, and if they provide a positive identification, it can later be used as evidence against the accused. The six-pack presented to Ledezma displayed images of himself alongside five other men. His mugshot had been circled, and the letters MP were written underneath, along with the words, This is who shot my friend's boyfriend, followed by Martha Puebla's signature. Ledezma remained steadfast and refused to confess.
这些照片会展示给目击者，如果他们做出明确辨认，以后就可以用作指控被告的证据。向莱德斯马展示的六人照上印有他自己的照片以及其他五名男子的照片。他的嫌疑人登记照被圈了起来，下方写着“MP”字样，还有“这就是枪击我朋友男友的人”这句话，后面跟着玛莎·普埃布拉的签名。莱德斯马立场坚定，拒绝招供。
When shown a picture of Martha Puebla, he maintained he didn't know her, but Detective Pinar pressed on, remarking, Well, she knows you. The interrogation of Mario Catalan was equally ineffectual, even when he was confronted with test results that had proven the firearm recovered from his vehicle was the one used in the shootings. Police set Catalan's bail at $1.25 million, and he was placed in a holding cell with his co-accused, where the pair's conversations were recorded by a covert listening device. Catalan immediately told Ledezma about the gun, who in turn sounded particularly agitated,
当被出示玛莎·普埃布拉的照片时，他坚称自己不认识她，但平纳侦探穷追不舍，评论道：“嗯，她认识你。”对马里奥·卡塔兰的审讯同样毫无成效，即使在向他出示了证明从他车里回收的枪支就是枪击案中使用的枪支的测试结果时也是如此。警方将卡塔兰的保释金定为125万美元，并把他关进了一个与他同案被告共用的牢房里，两人的谈话被隐蔽的窃听装置录了下来。卡塔兰立即把枪的事告诉了莱德斯马，莱德斯马随即显得格外激动，
but neither said anything that implicated them in the murders. Rumours circulated among gang members that Martha Puebla was to blame for Ledezma's criminal charges, and on Thursday, May 1, 2003, the 16-year-old was forced to testify at his and Mario Catalan's preliminary hearing, where both men faced charges for the murders of Christian Vargas and Onrique Acosta. Martha was noted as a reluctant witness, impacted by anxiety and fear, and unwilling to say anything in front of the defendants that might put her in danger. When asked to point to the shooter, she claimed she was unable to do so, as she hadn't seen
但两人都没有说出任何将他们与谋杀案联系起来的话。帮派成员中流传着谣言，称玛莎·普埃布拉是莱德斯马面临刑事指控的罪魁祸首；2003年5月1日星期四，这位16岁的女孩被迫在他和马里奥·卡塔兰的初步听证会上作证，两名男子都在会上地面临谋杀克里斯蒂安·巴尔加斯和恩里克·阿科斯塔的指控。玛莎被认为是一个不情愿的证人，受到焦虑和恐惧的影响，不愿意在被告面前说任何可能让自己陷入危险的话。当被要求指出枪手是谁时，她声称自己做不到，因为她没有看清
him well enough. Just over a week later, on the night of Monday, May 12, 2003, Martha was sitting and chatting with friends on the curb outside her home. As they talked, a black four-door Honda Accord with tinted windows circled the block several times, but the group paid little attention. Shortly after 10.30pm, Martha and her friend Lucas were the only ones remaining on the curb. The Honda Accord had returned and was idling nearby.
他的样子。仅仅一周多后，即2003年5月12日星期一晚上，玛莎正坐在自家门外的路缘上和朋友们聊天。他们说话时，一辆贴有深色车膜的黑色四门本田雅阁在街区盘旋了好几次，但大家都没怎么在意。晚上10点30分刚过，玛莎和她的朋友卢卡斯是仅有的留在路缘上的人。那辆本田雅阁又回来了，正在附近怠速行驶。
One of its passengers, a young male, emerged and approached Martha. He demanded to know who she was, and she responded, I'm Martha. You know me. Without hesitating, the man reached into his sweatshirt pocket, pulled out a 9mm handgun, and fired several shots at Martha at close range. He jumped back into the Honda, which sped away, as several residents cautiously emerged from their homes to investigate the noise.
其中的一名乘客，一个年轻男子，从车里钻出来走向玛莎。他质问她是谁，她回答说：“我是玛莎。你认识我。”男子毫不犹豫地把手伸进卫衣口袋，掏出一把9毫米手枪，近距离向玛莎连开数枪。他跳回本田车，汽车加速逃离，几位居民小心翼翼地从家中出来查看动静。
When Martha's mother realized her daughter had been shot, she let out an anguished scream that could be heard throughout the neighborhood, and cried out in Spanish, My God, she's dead. Police cordoned off Lull Street, and as one officer comforted Martha's parents, he recognized her name and contacted Detective Martin Pinner to inform him that one of the key witnesses in his case against Jose Ledesma was now deceased. Detective Pinner and his partner, Detective Juan Rodriguez, were convinced that Martha was either murdered in retaliation for testifying at Ledesma's preliminary hearing, or to ensure
当玛莎的母亲意识到女儿中枪时，她发出了一声痛苦的尖叫，整个社区都能听到，她用西班牙语哭喊道：“我的上帝，她死了。”警察拉起了警戒线封锁了勒尔街，一名警官在安慰玛莎的父母时，认出了她的名字，并联系了马丁·平纳侦探，通知他针对何塞·莱德斯马一案中的关键证人之一现在已经去世。平纳侦探和他的搭档胡安·罗德里格斯侦探确信，玛莎被谋杀要么是为了报复她在莱德斯马的预审中作证，要么是为了确保
she wouldn't be able to give evidence once the case proceeded to trial. The slaying would also serve as a powerful warning to other potential witnesses to reconsider cooperating with law enforcement. The message was received loud and clear, with attempts to gather information about Martha's death coming up dry, even though several people had observed the gunman flee. They tracked down Martha's friend to Lucas, whom she had been chatting with at the time she was killed. He had fled the scene immediately after the shooting, explaining that he feared for his
案件进入审判阶段后她无法提供证据。这场谋杀还将作为对其他潜在证人的一次有力警告，让他们重新考虑是否与执法部门合作。这个信息被清清楚楚地接收到了，尽管有几个人目睹了枪手逃跑，但收集关于玛莎死因信息的尝试却毫无结果。他们追踪到了玛莎的朋友卢卡斯，也就是她被杀时正聊天的对象。他在枪击事件发生后立即逃离了现场，解释说他担心自己的
life. Although Lucas was hesitant to get involved in the investigation, he eventually agreed to assist the police in creating a composite sketch of the perpetrator. He described the shooter as a Latino male, aged between 19 and 25, approximately 5 foot 8 to 5 foot 10 inches tall, with a stocky build, short hair, a mustache, and a small amount of facial hair beneath his lower lip. For their own protection, Martha's parents, Martha Router, and Regulo Puebla were relocated into state, while their daughter was laid to rest near her hometown at the San Fernando
生命安全。尽管卢卡斯对参与调查有所犹豫，但他最终同意协助警方制作嫌疑人的拼图画像。他将枪手描述为一名拉丁裔男子，年龄在19岁至25岁之间，身高约5英尺8英寸至5英尺10英寸（约1.73米至1.78米），身材健壮，留着短发、胡须，下唇下方有一小撮面部毛发。为了保护自身安全，玛莎的父母——玛莎·鲁特和雷古洛·普埃布拉被转移到了州内，而他们的女儿则在距离她家乡附近的圣费尔南多
Mission Cemetery. She was remembered as a caring aunt to her seven-year-old nephew, and her headstone was engraved with the words, We will always carry you in our hearts. On June 7, more than three weeks after Martha's murder, the Los Angeles City Council offered a $25,000 reward for information leading to the arrest and conviction of the person responsible. Meanwhile, investigators focused on identifying violent boys' members who matched the suspect's sketch. It was a difficult task, given that the gang was largely comprised of young Latinos with
传教士墓地安息。人们记住她是她七岁侄子的慈爱阿姨，她的墓碑上刻着这样一句话：“我们将永远把你放在心中。”在玛莎遇害三周多后的6月7日，洛杉矶市议会悬赏25,000美元，以征集能将肇事者捉拿归案并定罪的信息。与此同时，调查人员将重点放在识别符合嫌疑人画像的暴力男孩帮成员上。这是一项艰巨的任务，因为该帮派主要由年轻的拉丁裔人组成，他们都有
short dark hair and facial hair. Yet, there was one man in particular that stood out, 24-year-old Juan Catalan. He was the younger brother of Mario Catalan, Jose Ledezma's co-accused in the murders of Enrique Acosta and Christian Vargas. Juan had been in court during the preliminary hearing in which Martha Puebla had testified, and he lived five blocks from Lull Street. He had a familial connection to the violent boys, and investigators believed his appearance matched the sketch of Martha's killer.
短黑发和面部毛发。然而，有一个人格外显眼，那就是24岁的胡安·卡塔兰。他是马里奥·卡塔兰的弟弟，而马里奥是何塞·莱德斯马在恩里克·阿科斯塔和克里斯蒂安·巴尔加斯谋杀案中的同案被告。胡安在玛莎·普埃布拉作证的初审期间曾出庭，而且他就住在离勒尔街五个街区的地方。他与暴力男孩帮有着家族联系，调查人员认为他的外貌与玛莎遇害凶手的画像相符。
Lead detectives Pina and Rodriguez were certain Juan was motivated by a desire to protect his older brother from information Martha could provide at trial. Using a pre-existing mugshot of Juan Catalan, the detectives created a six-pack and showed it to witnesses of Martha Puebla's murder, including her friend DeLucas, to determine if any could make a positive identification. Juan and Mario Catalan had always been close. The brothers were raised in Sun Valley, where they were expected to follow in the footsteps of their hard-working father who owned a machinery store.
主办侦探皮纳和罗德里格斯确信，胡安的动机是保护他的哥哥免受玛莎可能在审判中提供的证据的伤害。利用胡安·卡塔兰现有的嫌疑人登记照，侦探们制作了一张“六人照”，并将其展示给玛莎·普埃布拉谋杀案的目击者（包括她的朋友德卢卡斯），以确定是否有人能做出明确辨认。胡安和马里奥·卡塔兰一直很亲密。这两兄弟在太阳谷长大，人们希望他们能追随他们拥有一家机械商店的勤劳父亲的脚步。
By the time the siblings were in their teens, Juan dropped out of high school to work for the family business as expected, but Mario had started associating with criminals and participating in illicit activities. Intrigued by the loot his older brother would bring home from his crime sprees, Juan agreed to act as Mario's getaway driver, a decision which landed him in jail. Prison rattled Juan, and he was determined never to return. Therefore, when Mario joined the Vineland Boys, Juan didn't follow suit. Instead, he continued working with his father and started a family with a woman named Dalmar.
到了兄弟俩十几岁的时候，胡安按照预期从高中辍学，为家族企业工作，但马里奥开始与罪犯交往并参与非法活动。胡安对哥哥从犯罪狂欢中带回家的战利品很感兴趣，便同意担任马里奥的逃跑司机，这个决定让他锒铛入狱。监狱让胡安感到恐慌，他决心绝不再回去。因此，当马里奥加入瓦兰德男孩帮时，胡安并没有效仿。相反，他继续和父亲一起工作，并和一个名叫达尔玛的女人组建了家庭。
Their relationship was punctuated with disputes, and by the time their two daughters were aged four and six, the couple were living apart, though refused to give up on their relationship. At 6am on Tuesday, August 12, 2003, Alma drove Juan to work while the couple's four-year-old daughter sat in the back seat. When Alma stopped the car, three vehicles appeared and parked crossways in front of them, cutting off their path. Juan exited the vehicle and was immediately swarmed by 10 armed undercover police officers who warded him to get on his knees. He complied and was then pinned to the ground and taken into custody.
他们的关系充满了争吵，当他们的两个女儿分别四岁和六岁时，这对夫妇开始分居，尽管达尔玛拒绝放弃这段关系。2003年8月12日星期二早上6点，阿尔玛开车送胡安去上班，这对夫妇四岁的女儿坐在后座上。当阿尔玛停车时，出现了三辆车，呈十字形停在他们前方，切断了他们的去路。胡安下了车，立刻被10名武装便衣警察包围，命令他跪下。他照做了，随后被按倒在地并被拘留。
Juan was driven to a North Hollywood police station where he was kept in a cell for several hours before being led into an interview room to be questioned by detectives Pinar and Rodriguez. He asked why he had been taken into custody, but both detectives insisted that he knew exactly why. When asked about his whereabouts three months earlier on the night of May 12, 2003, Juan said he couldn't recall. The detectives then reminded him of his right to remain silent and informed him that he was under arrest for the murder of 16-year-old Martha Puebla. Juan was told he resembled the composite sketch of Martha's killer, and that witnesses had identified him as the gunman.
胡安被带到北好莱坞警察局，在一个牢房里关了好几个小时，然后被带到审讯室接受平纳和罗德里格斯侦探的盘问。他询问自己为什么被拘留，但两名侦探坚称他心里很清楚原因。当被问及三个月前（即2003年5月12日晚）他的行踪时，胡安说他记不清了。侦探们随后提醒他有权保持沉默，并告知他因谋杀16岁的玛莎·普埃布拉而被捕。胡安被告知他长得像玛莎遇害凶手的拼图画像，且目击者已辨认出他就是枪手。
The detectives produced three six-packs that fidgeted Juan's old mug shot, which had been circled in each. Written in Spanish underneath one were the words, this is the guy who I saw doing the shooting, accompanied by a signature. Detective Rodriguez remarked, you see, the pitches don't lie. Beth Silverman was a tough, smart prosecutor who held a coveted record for never losing a murder conviction. Her colleagues had nicknamed her the Sniper because she always sought the death penalty. It was no different when she helmed the trial for Martha Puebla's murder, with Silverman informing the county court that she would be seeking a death sentence for Juan Catalan.
侦探们出示了三张六人照，上面都有胡安旧的嫌疑人登记照，每张照片上的照片都被圈了起来。其中一张下面用西班牙语写着：“这就是我看到开枪的那个人”，并附有签名。罗德里格斯侦探评论道：“你看，照片是不会说谎的。”贝丝·西尔弗曼是一位强硬、精明的检察官，她保持着从未输掉过谋杀罪定罪的令人艳羡的记录。她的同事给她取了个绰号叫“狙击手”，因为她总是寻求死刑。当她负责玛莎·普埃布拉谋杀案的审判时也没有例外，西尔弗曼通知县法院，她将为胡安·卡塔兰寻求死刑判决。
In the meantime, Juan was sent to a high-security prison to await further proceedings. He was stripped naked, subjected to a full-body search, and crammed into a small room with a hundred other prisoners before they were issued with uniforms. He was then assigned to an overcrowded cell where he was given a thin mattress on the concrete ground to sleep on. Conditions were filthy, with the shower drains backing up to the point that the prisoners felt as though they were bathing in their own filth. A cousin of Juan's was employed as a filing clerk for a law firm and would often rave about one of the officer's criminal defense attorneys, Todd Melnick. He once told Juan that if he ever got into trouble, Melnick would be the one to call,
与此同时，胡安被送往一所高度戒备的监狱等待进一步的诉讼程序。他被剥光衣服，接受了全身搜查，并与另外一百名囚犯挤在一个小房间里，然后才分发了制服。随后，他被分配到一个拥挤的牢房里，水泥地面上只给了一张薄床垫供他睡觉。环境极其肮脏，淋浴排水管甚至倒灌，以至于囚犯们觉得他们像是在自己的污垢中洗澡。胡安的一个表亲是一家律所的文件管理员，经常对其中一位警官的刑事辩护律师托德·梅尔尼克赞不绝口。他曾对胡安说，如果他惹上麻烦，一定要找梅尔尼克，
to which Juan responded, Bro, nobody here needs a lawyer. After he had been charged with Martha Puebla's murder, Juan reached out to Melnick, who prided himself on working hard for his clients in cases that required in-depth investigation and analysis. Melnick claimed to have a shadow seasoned Los Angeles Police Department detectives when it came to diligent fact-finding and using the latest techniques and technologies. A satisfied client of Melnick's was quoted as saying, in a town of charlatans, this guy is the real deal. Melnick visited Juan in prison to decide whether to take on his case. When the accused killer
对此胡安回应道：“老兄，这里没人需要律师。”在被指控谋杀玛莎·普埃布拉之后，胡安联系了梅尔尼克。梅尔尼克以在需要深入调查和分析的案件中为客户努力工作而自豪。梅尔尼克声称，在勤奋搜寻事实以及使用最新技术和技巧方面，他甚至能让经验丰富的洛杉矶警察局侦探相形见绌。梅尔尼克的一位满意的客户曾说过：“在这个江湖骗子横行的城镇里，这家伙才是真正的硬汉。”梅尔尼克去监狱探视了胡安，以决定是否接手他的案子。当这位被指控的杀手
professed his innocence and explained that he was being framed by the police, Melnick felt he was being sincere. He later told current affairs program, 60 minutes. I could tell by Juan's demeanor. I could tell by his voice. He was an easy read. Juan attended multiple court hearings in the lead-up to his murder trial, during which he was shackled to a chair while the legal teams briefly conversed. He wasn't familiar with legal terminology and relied on his lawyer to keep him informed. At one hearing, Melnick advised his client that it was important that he looked straight ahead when entering the court as Martha Puebla's entire family was inside. Juan shuffled in
坚称自己无罪并解释说自己是被警方陷害时，梅尔尼克觉得他是真诚的。他后来告诉时事节目《60分钟》：“我从胡安的神态中能看出来。我从他的声音中能看出来。他很容易被看透。”在谋杀审判前的准备阶段，胡安出席了多次法庭听证会，期间他被锁在椅子上，而法律团队则在一旁简短交谈。他对法律术语并不熟悉，只能依靠律师来让他了解情况。在一次听证会上，梅尔尼克建议他的客户，进入法庭时一定要目视前方，因为玛莎·普埃布拉的整个家人都在里面。胡安低着头
with his head bowed and once seated, stared straight ahead as members of Martha's family sobbed. When the hearing was over and Juan was being led away, Martha's mother screamed at him in Spanish. I will never forgive you for what you did to my daughter. Juan's family visited him in prison and remained supportive, with his religious mother telling him that God would not allow him to be convicted of a crime he didn't commit and that justice would prevail. Although Juan refused to let his young daughters see him inside, he maintained regular contact with them and his girlfriend Alma over the telephone. During one call, Alma presented Juan with a possible alibi for the night Martha was murdered.
拖着步子走进来，一旦坐下就目视前方，而玛莎家人的啜泣声清晰可闻。听证会结束后，胡安被带走时，玛莎的母亲用西班牙语对大喊大叫：“我永远不会原谅你对我的女儿做的事。”胡安的家人去监狱探望了他并给予支持，他信教的母亲告诉他，上帝不会允许他因自己没犯过的罪而被定罪，正义终将战胜邪恶。尽管胡安拒绝让年幼的女儿们在里面探望他，但他通过电话与她们和女友阿尔玛保持着定期联系。在一次通话中，阿尔玛为胡安提供了一个玛莎被谋杀当晚的不在场证明。
Juan had always been a die-hard sports fan. As a child, he dreamed of growing up to become a professional basketballer and followed DLA Lakers basketball team religiously. When it came to American football, he was a San Francisco 49ers fan. He inherited his family's love of DLA Dodgers baseball team, with some of his earliest memories involving sharing a pair of binoculars with his brother as they sat side by side in the stadium's cheapest seats, known as the nosebleed section. It was a passion that he maintained into adulthood and when Juan was 18 years old, he watched as a player described as a Joe Schmo from the Dodger bench hit a two-run homer in the ninth inning. The ball sailed into the left field pavilion where Juan was seated and he caught
胡安一直是个死忠的体育迷。小时候，他梦想着长大后成为一名职业篮球运动员，并狂热地关注着洛杉矶湖人队。谈到美式足球时，他是旧金山49人队的球迷。他继承了家人对洛杉矶道奇队棒球队的热爱，他的一些最早记忆包括和哥哥并肩坐在球场最便宜的座位（被称为“流鼻血区”）里，共用一副双筒望远镜。这种热情一直保持到了成年，当胡安18岁时，他看到了一位被描述为道奇队替补席上“无名小卒”的球员在第九局击出了一记两分本垒打。棒球飞入了他所在的左外野露天看台，他
it flawlessly, fulfilling a lifelong dream. Although Juan's life could be unpredictable at times, his love of sports was constant. He attended every Dodgers and Lakers game he could, usually in the nosebleed section, but was occasionally lucky enough to secure good seats. He was keen to share his passion with his daughters and although six-year-old Melissa didn't really understand what was happening at the games, she loved the atmosphere. One day in May of 2003, a customer from Juan's work gave him four last-minute tickets to a game at Dodger Stadium, where the home team was playing against the Atlanta Braves. Juan took his daughter Melissa, his cousin, and another friend to the event. It had been a tired game
完美地接住了它，实现了一个终生的梦想。尽管胡安的生活有时难以预测，但对体育的热爱却始终如一。他尽可能地参加每一场道奇队和湖人队的比赛，通常坐在“流鼻血区”，但偶尔也很幸运能买到好座位。他热衷于与女儿们分享他的热情，尽管六岁的梅丽莎并不太懂比赛中发生了什么，但她很喜欢那里的气氛。2003年5月的一天，胡安工作的一位客户送给他四张道奇体育场比赛的最后时刻门票，主场球队将对阵亚特兰大勇士队。胡安带着女儿梅丽莎、表亲和另一个朋友去参加了这场活动。这是一场令人疲惫的比赛，
coming into the final inning, but the Dodgers ultimately lost 11-4. Juan kept all the sporting memorabilia and souvenirs from the games he attended, and was certain he retained the ticket stubs from the match. He gave Alma a list of places he thought they might be, but she was unable to find them. Todd Melnick instructed her to turn her entire apartment upside down if she had to, and in a dresser draw, she found two ticket stubs to the Dodgers vs Braves game which took place at Dodger Stadium on May 12, 2003. Melnick warned his client that the tickets alone wouldn't be enough to secure his release. All they proved was that somebody had been at the game that night, but not necessarily Juan
直到最后一局才分出胜负，但道奇队最终以11比4落败。胡安保留了他参加过的比赛的所有体育纪念品和纪念物，并且确信他保留了这场比赛的门票存根。他给阿尔玛列出了一份他认为可能存放这些东西的地方清单，但她没能找到。托德·梅尔尼克指示她，哪怕要把整个公寓翻个底朝天也要找出来，最终在一个梳妆台抽屉里，她找到了2003年5月12日在道奇体育场举行的道奇队对阵勇士队比赛的两张门票存根。梅尔尼克警告他的客户，仅凭这些门票还不足以确保他获释。它们只能证明那天晚上有人去了比赛，但未必就是胡安
himself. Juan's cousin and friend who joined him at the game both vouched for his presence, but Melnick didn't consider them to be reliable witnesses for the defense. The tickets featured seat numbers, so Melnick visited Dodger Stadium and was given access to footage captured by a video recording system known as Dodger Cam. He constantly panned the crowd and projected real-time footage onto the large display screens within the stadium. Melnick watched the footage taken on May 12, 2003, pausing frame by frame whenever the camera passed the area where Juan allegedly sat with his daughter. Melnick could make out two occupants in the seats,
本人。和胡安一起去观看比赛的表亲和朋友都为他的在场作证，但梅尔尼克并不认为他们是可靠的辩护证人。门票上有座位号，于是梅尔尼克实地考察了道奇体育场，并获得了被称作“道奇摄像机”（Dodger Cam）的视频记录系统所捕获的画面的访问权限。他不断扫视人群，并将实时画面投射到体育场内的大型显示屏幕上。梅尔尼克观看了2003年5月12日拍摄的画面，每当镜头经过胡安据称和女儿坐在一起的区域时，他就逐帧暂停。梅尔尼克能辨认出座位上有两个人，
but the footage was too blurry to make a positive identification. He also watched the entire three-hour long match that had been broadcast by the Fox Sports Channel, but shots taken around the pivotal seating section were too low a resolution to identify individual crowd members. Melnick reported his efforts to Juan, who suddenly remembered another detail from the game. At one point, he and Melissa were returning to their seats after a food and bathroom break, but their path was blocked by a television camera that didn't look like the ones used at the stadium. A production assistant asked Juan if he would mind waiting a few minutes while they filmed
但画面太模糊，无法做出明确辨认。他还观看了福克斯体育频道（Fox Sports Channel）转播的整场长达三个小时的比赛，但关键座位区周围拍摄的镜头分辨率太低，无法辨认出具体的观众。梅尔尼克向胡安汇报了他的努力，胡安突然想起了比赛中的另一个细节。有一点，他和梅丽莎在买完食物和上完厕所后正返回座位，但他们的去路被一台看起来不像体育场里使用的电视摄像机挡住了。一名制作助理问胡安是否介意等几分钟，以便他们拍摄
their shot. Juan could still see the pitch from behind the camera, so he politely agreed. He recalled that a bald-in Caucasian man was walking up and down the stairs, yelling in full view of the camera, but Juan was too focused on the game to remember anything else. After a short while, the production assistant permitted the father and daughter to return to their seats. Juan also recalled that someone in his section had mentioned that Super Dave Osborne was in attendance, but Juan didn't recognize the name. Todd Melnick learned that the Dodgers allowed outside film and television crews to shoot footage in the stadium from time to time, though it was rare for it to take place during an actual game, so as to avoid inconveniencing
镜头。胡安从摄像机后面仍然能看到球场，于是他礼貌地同意了。他回忆起一个秃顶的白人男子在台阶上走来走去，在摄像机的全景视野中大喊大叫，但胡安的注意力太集中在比赛上，记不起其他任何事情了。过了一会儿，制作助理允许这对父女回到他们的座位上。胡安还回忆起他那个区里有人提到“超级大卫·奥斯本”（Super Dave Osborne）也出席了比赛，但胡安并不认识这个名字。托德·梅尔尼克了解到，道奇队偶尔允许外部电影和电视摄制组在体育场拍摄镜头，尽管这在实际比赛期间很少发生，以免给
the paying fans. Melnick was given access to the stadium's records, and on May 12, 2003, there was just one entry in the filming log. Melnick called the accompanying phone number and a voice on the other end answered by stating, HBO. As it turned out, the American cable television network had been at the stadium that night filming an episode of their hit comedy series, Curb Your Enthusiasm. Super Dave Osborne, who Juan overheard was present at the game, was American comedian and actor Bob Einstein, who played a character on Curb Your Enthusiasm named Marty Funkauser. Curb Your Enthusiasm is a high-budget comedy series produced by and starring American comedian Larry David. Larry is best known as the co-creator of popular 90s sitcom
买票的球迷带来不便。梅尔尼克获得了体育场记录的查阅权限，在2003年5月12日，拍摄日志中只有一个条目。梅尔尼克拨通了随附的电话号码，那头的一个声音回答说：“HBO。”原来，这家美国有线电视网络那天晚上一直在体育场拍摄他们热门喜剧系列剧《抑制热情》（Curb Your Enthusiasm）的一集。胡安无意中听到在场的超级大卫·奥斯本其实就是美国喜剧演员兼演员鲍勃·爱因斯坦（Bob Einstein），他在《抑制热情》中扮演了一个名叫马蒂·方克豪瑟（Marty Funkhouser）的角色。《抑制热情》是一部高预算的喜剧系列剧，由美国喜剧演员拉里·大卫（Larry David）制作并主演。拉里最为人所知的身份是90年代热门情景喜剧
Seinfeld, and is rumored to have been the inspiration for the show's neurotic and petty character of George Costanza. In Curb Your Enthusiasm, Larry plays a fictionalized version of himself, with all his neuroses and quirks exaggerated for comedic effect. The show premiered on October 15, 2000, and follows Larry, a semi-retired television writer and producer in Los Angeles, focusing primarily on the many faux pas he makes when faced with certain social conventions and expectations. When Todd Milnick contacted HBO to request the footage taken in Dodger Stadium on May 12, 2003, he was met with reluctance. That particular episode of Curb Your Enthusiasm hadn't aired yet, and was scheduled to premiere the following spring. HBO was strict about
《宋飞传》（Seinfeld）的共同创作者，据传他是该剧中神经质且琐碎的角色乔治·科斯坦扎（George Costanza）的灵感来源。在《抑制热情》中，拉里扮演了一个虚构版本的自己，他所有的神经质和怪癖都被为了喜剧效果而夸大了。该剧于2000年10月15日首播，讲述了拉里这位洛杉矶半退休电视编剧和制片人的故事，主要聚焦于他在面对某些社会习俗和期望时犯下的许多失礼行为。当托德·梅尔尼克联系HBO请求获取2003年5月12日在道奇体育场拍摄的画面时，他遇到了阻力。那一集的《抑制热情》尚未播出，计划在第二年春天首播。HBO对
pre-production footage being viewed by anyone outside the network, but Milnick explained to the situation and pressed executives, stating it was a matter of life or death. HBO told him it was unlikely he would be able to locate his client in their footage, as there had only been two cameras in operation, and there were more than 56,000 patrons at the game. Nevertheless, Milnick was so passionate and convincing that his request was put through to Larry David himself. Noting the attorney's bizarre story could have been the plot for an episode of Curb Your Enthusiasm, Larry permitted Milnick to view the footage. Milnick visited the HBO Studios in Santa Monica, where he was placed in an editing room with the
由网罗外部人员观看前期制作画面一事非常严格，但梅尔尼克向高管们说明了情况并施加了压力，称这是一条人命关天的事。HBO告诉他，他不太可能在他们的画面中找到他的客户，因为当时只有两台摄像机在运作，而且比赛现场有超过56,000名观众。尽管如此，梅尔尼克还是表现得如此热情且令人信服，以至于他的请求被直接转达给了拉里·大卫本人。注意到这位律师离奇的故事本可以成为《抑制热情》一集的情节后，拉里允许梅尔尼克观看画面。梅尔尼克参观了位于圣莫尼卡的HBO工作室，在那里他被安排与该
show's producers, and granted access to all the rough footage from episode 7 of season 4, titled The Carpool Lane. In the episode, Larry is in a hurry to get to a Dodgers game and hires a sex worker to ride as a passenger in his car so that he can use the highway's carpool lane. Upon arriving to the stadium, Larry is upset that he has to sit in what he considers to be lousy seats. In one scene, he briefly walks down the aisle in an attempt to join his friend, Marty Funkhauser, who is sitting in a field-level seat. While viewing the footage, Milnick recognized the stand where Juan was allegedly seated with his daughter, but there was no sign of them. On the fifth or sixth tape, the camera was following Larry as he
剧的制片人一起待在一个剪辑室里，并获准查阅第四季第七集（名为《拼车道》（The Carpool Lane））的所有粗剪画面。在这一集中，拉里急着去看道奇队的比赛，于是雇了一名性工作者作为乘客坐在他的车里，以便他能使用高速公路的拼车道。到达体育场后，拉里对不得不坐在他认为很烂的座位上感到很不满。在一个场景中，他短暂地走过通道，试图去找他的朋友马蒂·方克豪瑟，后者坐在底层球场的座位上。在观看画面时，梅尔尼克认出了胡安据称和女儿坐在一起的看台，但没有他们的踪影。在第五或第六卷磁带上，摄像机正跟着拉里
ascended the stairs from the field-level seats, when a man in a white Dodgers t-shirt with the number 27 on the back walked in the shot. He was eating a hot dog and holding the hand of a little girl, seemingly oblivious that he was about to cut off the star of the show. As the man turned to take his seat, his face was clearly visible. Milnick nearly leapt out of his chair and pointed at the screen, announcing, that's him right there. Roll that tape back. Despite the breakthrough, the footage was time-stamped at 9.10 pm. Lowell Street was a 16-mile north-westerly drive from Dodger Stadium, and the journey typically took upwards of 30 minutes, not withstanding inner-city baseball game traffic.
从底层球场座位爬上台阶，这时一个穿着背面印有27号的白色道奇T恤的男子走进了镜头。他正吃着热狗，手里拉着一个小女孩，似乎全然不知自己即将挡住大明星的去路。当男子转身准备入座时，他的脸清晰可见。梅尔尼克差点从椅子上跳起来，指着屏幕宣布：“就是他。把录像带倒回去。”尽管取得了突破，但画面的时间戳是晚上9点10分。勒尔街距离道奇体育场有16英里向西北方向的车程，考虑到市内棒球比赛的交通，这段行程通常需要30分钟以上。
As Martha Puebler was killed an hour and 20 minutes later at 10.32 pm, Milnick knew the prosecution could argue it was possible that Juan had left the stadium before the game ended, shortly after 10 pm, to carry out the shooting. Complicating matters was the fact that Juan himself had even admitted to being on Lowell Street 10 minutes after Martha's murder. He was dropping off his cousin after the game, who lived 150 yards away. However, he insisted he would never have left the game early when it was a tie going into the ninth inning. When Milnick asked for further proof, Juan remembered he had purchased souvenir baseball cards at the end of the match. However, as he had paid for them with cash, there was no record of
由于玛莎·普埃布拉在1小时20分钟后的晚上10点32分被杀，梅尔尼克知道控方可以辩称，胡安完全有可能在比赛结束前（即晚上10点刚过不久）离开体育场去实施枪击。使情况变得复杂的是，胡安自己甚至承认在玛莎被谋杀10分钟后出现在勒尔街。他是在比赛结束后送他的表亲回家，他表亲就住在150码外。然而，他坚称在第九局打平的情况下，他绝不可能提前离开比赛。当梅尔尼克要求提供进一步的证据时，胡安想起他在比赛结束时买过纪念棒球卡。然而，由于他是用现金支付的，因此没有
the transaction. Cell phone records revealed that at 10.13 pm, Juan had taken up 49-second phone call from Alma. This detail reminded Milnick of his time spent observing the infamous 1995 trial of NFL player OJ Simpson, who was accused of murdering his ex-wife Nicole Brown Simpson and her friend Ron Goldman. After he was charged with the murders, Simpson refused to turn himself in and was involved in a low-speed police pursuit, which was televised and watched by an estimated 95 million viewers. Simpson was using a cell phone during the chase, and police were able to confirm his location by verifying which cell towers the device was pinging off at the time. Milnick decided to use this same technique and subpoenaed Juan Catalan's phone records from
这笔交易的记录。手机记录显示，晚上10点13分，胡安接听了阿尔玛打来的49秒电话。这个细节让梅尔尼克想起了他当年观察1995年轰动一时的美式足球联盟（NFL）球员O·J·辛普森（OJ Simpson）审判时的经历，辛普森被指控谋杀他的前妻妮可·布朗·辛普森（Nicole Brown Simpson）及其朋友罗恩·戈德曼（Ron Goldman）。被指控谋杀后，辛普森拒绝自首，并卷入了一场低速警察追逐战，该追逐战通过电视直播，估计有9500万观众观看。辛普森在追逐过程中使用了一台手机，警察通过验证当时设备的信号连接了哪个手机基站，从而确认了他的位置。梅尔尼克决定使用这种相同技术，并传唤了胡安·卡塔兰在
the night of May 12, 2003. They confirmed that the 10.13 pm call from Alma had pinged off a tower alongside Dodger Stadium. Even if Juan had been able to reach Lowell Street within the 20-minute timeframe to execute Martha Puebla at 10.32 pm, witnesses had seen the perpetrator's vehicle circling the neighborhood around 10 pm, when Juan was still at Dodger Stadium. Juan's preliminary hearing commenced in January 2004. Todd Milnick presented all of the evidence he had collected that placed his client at Dodger Stadium immediately prior to Martha Puebla's murder. Juan's young daughter Melissa took the stand and testified to attending the Dodgers game with her father, during which she remembered they bought ice cream and souvenir baseball cards.
2003年5月12日晚上的手机记录。它们证实，来自阿尔玛的晚上10点13分的电话连接的是道奇体育场旁边的基站。即使胡安能够在20分钟的时间框架内赶到勒尔街并在晚上10点32分处决玛莎·普埃布拉，目击者也在晚上10点左右（当时胡安还在道奇体育场）看到肇事车辆在社区周围盘旋。胡安的初审于2004年1月开始。托德·梅尔尼克出示了他收集的所有证据，证明他的客户在玛莎·普埃布拉被谋杀前不久一直呆在道奇体育场。胡安年幼的女儿梅丽莎出庭作证，证明她和父亲一起参加了道奇队的比赛，期间她记得他们买过冰淇淋和纪念棒球卡。
The prosecution remained dubious about Juan's alibi, questioning why he didn't mention it when he was first interviewed by detectives. Juan maintained he had been in shock at the time and unable to think clearly. Tapes of his initial police interrogation were played in court, wherein a worried Juan continuously asserted his innocence to detectives Martin Pinar and Juan Rodriguez. On three occasions, he pleaded to sit a polygraph test, but the detectives ignored the request and continued to accuse him of Martha Puebla's murder. The prosecution had learned of Juan's baseball game alibi during pre-trial proceedings, but had dismissed it, convinced he had enough time to leave the stadium and carry out the crime. His cell phone records proved
检方对胡安的不在场证明仍持怀疑态度，质问他为什么在最初接受侦探盘问时没有提及此事。胡安坚称自己当时处于震惊状态，无法清晰思考。法庭上播放了他最初接受警方审讯的录像，录像中焦虑的胡安不断向侦探马丁·皮纳和胡安·罗德里格斯坚称自己是无辜的。他曾三次恳求进行测谎仪测试，但侦探们忽视了这一请求，并继续指控他谋杀玛莎·普埃布拉。检方在审前程序中获悉了胡安的棒球赛不在场证明，但予以驳回，确信他有足够的时间离开球场去作案。他的手机通话记录证明了
otherwise and served to highlight the failure of the case detectives to carry out a thorough investigation to find out this information for themselves. It also indicated their reluctance to try and clear their prime suspect. Melnick also pointed out that there were discrepancies in the eyewitness accounts of Martha's killer, who was described as having facial hair beneath his lower lip, which Juan never had. The killer was also said to have a stocky frame between 5'8 and 5'10 inches tall, while Juan was 6'1 with a lean build. Lucas, Martha's friend who witnessed her murder, provided this description to police and appeared in court as the prosecution's star witness. When asked if he could see the shooter in the courthouse, Lucas pointed directly
事实并非如此，这也凸显了案件侦探未能开展彻底调查以自行查明这些信息的失职。这也表明他们不愿尝试为头号嫌疑人洗清嫌疑。梅尔尼克还指出，目击者对玛莎凶手的描述存在矛盾，凶手被描述为下唇下方有面部毛发，而胡安从来没有。据说凶手身材魁梧，身高在5英尺8英寸到5英尺10英寸之间，而胡安身高6英尺1英寸，身材苗条。玛莎的朋友卢卡斯目睹了她的谋杀案，他向警方提供了这一描述，并作为检方的王牌证人出庭。当被问及是否能在法庭上看到枪手时，卢卡斯直接指向
at Juan Catalan, who silently shook his head. While Judge Leslie Dunn considered Lucas to be credible and honest, she noted that the execution had occurred swiftly in a dimly lit street. Additionally, Lucas panicked and fled the scene immediately. Therefore, his memory might not be accurate. Judge Dunn ultimately accepted the HBO footage and Phone Tower evidence as proof of Juan Catalan's alibi, and ruled that it was near impossible for him to have reached Martha's house in time to carry out the shooting. Therefore, she concluded he could not be committed to stand trial for a crime that carried the death penalty. Unable to comprehend what the judge was saying, Juan turned to his attorney, who clarified,
胡安·卡塔兰，后者默默地摇了摇头。虽然莱斯利·邓恩法官认为卢卡斯诚实可信，但她指出枪击事件发生在一条光线昏暗的街道上，转瞬即逝。此外，卢卡斯当时惊慌失措并立即逃离了现场。因此，他的记忆可能并不准确。邓恩法官最终接受了HBO录像和手机基站证据作为胡安·卡塔兰不在场证明的证据，并裁定他几乎不可能及时赶到玛莎家实施枪击。因此，她得出结论，不能以可能判处死刑的罪名将他交付审判。胡安无法理解法官在说些什么，便转向他的律师，后者澄清道，
It's over. Overwhelmed by the news that he was free to go, Juan began to cry. Juan Catalan was released immediately, with camera crews capturing him in an emotional embrace with Alma and their two daughters. He later told reporters, To hear the words from the judge's mouth, I just broke down in tears. It was the happiest moment in my life. During his five and a half months in prison, he had lost 30 pounds, and his first request was for a Coca-Cola. Juan gave Todd Melnick one last hug before departing with his family to purchase the drink. Melnick later told the New York Post newspaper, If Juan had been home the night of the shooting, he might be on death row right now.
一切都结束了。得知自己重获自由的消息后，胡安激动得哭了起来。胡安·卡塔兰立即获释，摄像机镜头捕捉到了他与阿尔玛及两个女儿感人至深的拥抱。他后来告诉记者：“听到法官说出那些话，我当场泪崩。这是我一生中最幸福的时刻。”在监狱度过的五年半时间里，他瘦了30磅，他的第一个愿望就是喝一杯可口可乐。胡安在与家人离开去买饮料前，最后一次拥抱了托德·梅尔尼克。梅尔尼克后来告诉《纽约邮报》：“如果胡安在枪击当晚在家，他现在可能正身处死刑犯牢房。”
That's how crazy this was. Only by happenstance did he get tickets to go to the game that night. Only by happenstance would Curb your enthusiasm be filming in his section that night. Two days after Juan's release, he was forced to report back to the county jail due to an alleged clerical error. Melnick believed the matter would be settled within 24 hours, but Juan was held in custody for another two weeks. After his release, Juan purchased the box set of Curb your enthusiasm. Although he had since become a fan of the sitcom due to the impact it had on his life, he was embarrassed to admit that before his ordeal, he had never heard of it or Larry David. Juan stated, From getting the tickets on the day of to being caught on camera,
事情就是这么疯狂。他只是偶然拿到了当晚比赛的门票。也只是偶然间，《抑制热情》剧组当晚会在他的区域拍摄。胡安获释两天后，由于所谓的文书错误，他被迫向县监狱报到。梅尔尼克相信此事会在24小时内解决，但胡安又被拘留了两周。获释后，胡安买下了《抑制热情》的盒装光盘。尽管由于这部剧对他人生的重大影响，他后来成了这部情景喜剧的粉丝，但他尴尬地承认，在经历这场磨难之前，他从未听说过这部剧或拉里·戴维。胡安表示：“从当天买到票到被镜头拍到，
what are the chances that out of 56 to 58,000 seats they're filming on my aisle? I look at it like I did win the lottery because I got a new opportunity at life with my family. I'm so happy and grateful for that. Larry David later reflected on the vital role he show played in securing Juan's freedom, remarking, I tell people that I've done one decent thing in my life, albeit inadvertently. Juan and Larry eventually met and after being warned the comedian was a germaphobe, Juan was pleasantly surprised when Larry shook his hand. Although Juan's release was a positive outcome for him and his family, it was devastating for Martha Pueblo's parents. As they didn't speak English,
在5.6万到5.8万个座位中，他们偏偏在我的过道拍摄，这几率有多大？我觉得自己就像中了彩票，因为我和家人获得了崭新的人生机遇。我对此感到非常高兴和感激。”拉里·戴维后来反思了这部剧在确保胡安重获自由方面所发挥的关键作用，他评论道：“我告诉人们，我这辈子做了一件正经事，尽管是无意中做的。”胡安和拉里最终见面了，在被警告这位喜剧演员有洁癖后，当拉里主动跟他握手时，胡安感到又惊又喜。尽管胡安的获释对他和他的家人来说是一个积极的结果，但对玛莎·普埃布拉的父母来说却是毁灭性的打击。由于他们不会说英语，
they relied on the police to inform them about the case and court proceedings and had been assured that their daughter's murderer had been caught and would pay for his crime. When the case against Juan was dropped, they couldn't understand the sudden turn of events and thought that he may have been let off on a technicality or by the work of a clever lawyer. Confused and grief-stricken, Martha's mother went to Juan's workplace and screamed for him to come out and get what he deserved, but he wasn't there at the time. Following his ordeal, Juan Catalan was diagnosed with post-traumatic stress disorder. In mid-2004, he sued the city of Los Angeles, the Los Angeles Police Department,
他们只能依靠警察来了解案件和法庭审理的进展，并且被告知他们女儿的谋杀犯已经被抓获，将为他的罪行付出代价。当针对胡安的案件被撤销时，他们无法理解事态的突然转变，以为他是因为技术漏洞或某个聪明律师的操作而被释放的。困惑和悲痛欲绝的玛莎母亲来到胡安的工作单位，尖叫着让他出来得到他应得的下场，但他当时并不在那里。经历这场磨难后，胡安·卡塔兰被诊断患有创伤后应激障碍。2004年中期，他起诉了洛杉矶市、洛杉矶警察局，
and four detectives, including Martin Pinar and Juan Rodriguez, for violating his civil rights and failing to investigate his alibi or pursue any other leads. He also accused law enforcement of breaching department regulations by encouraging a witness to pick him out of a photographic lineup and sued them for negligence, false arrest, defamation, and inflection of emotional distress. For the stress and anguish caused, he sued an undisclosed financial compensation. Juan told reporters, What they did to me was very wrong. They put me through hell. I was arrested at gunpoint in front of my four-year-old daughter when she was crying. They took me away from my family.
以及包括马丁·皮纳和胡安·罗德里格斯在内的四名侦探，指控他们侵犯其民事权利，且未调查其不在场证明或追查任何其他线索。他还指控执法部门违反部门规定，怂恿证人在照片辨认中指认他，并以疏忽、错误逮捕、诽谤和造成精神痛苦起诉他们。为了赔偿所受到的压力和痛苦，他索取了未公开金额的经济赔偿。胡安告诉记者：“他们对我的所作所为大错特错。他们让我经历了地狱般的折磨。在我四岁女儿哭泣的时候，他们拿枪指着把我逮捕。他们把我从家人身边带走。
My parents almost lost their house and small business, but mainly, they took my life away. I was in jail for five months for nothing. His civil suit attorney, Gary Castleman, told the media, No amount of money can replace a loss like this. This was a nightmare that only by good fortune turned out right. The detectives in this case didn't do their jobs properly and they didn't follow proper procedures. Todd Melnick did the job the police were supposed to have done and paid to do. It was incompetence. They took the easy way out. Castleman explained that Juan consequently had to spend a tremendous sum of money to clear his name,
我的父母差点失去了房子和小生意，但最重要的是，他们夺走了我的人生。我无缘无故在监狱里呆了五个月。”他的民事诉讼律师加里·卡斯尔曼对媒体表示：“再多的钱也无法弥补这样的损失。这是一场仅凭好运才得以纠正的噩梦。本案的侦探没有尽到职责，也没有遵循正确的程序。托德·梅尔尼克做了警察本该做且拿着薪水应该做的工作。这就是无能。他们走了捷径。”卡斯尔曼解释说，胡安因此不得不花费巨资来洗清罪名，
remarking, Now it's their turn to pay. In a shocking revelation, while under cross-examination, detectives Pinar and Rodriguez admitted to fabricating evidence to implicate Juan Catalan in Martha Puebla's murder. In the United States, detectives are not obligated to tell the truth when interrogating suspects and are permitted to lie in an attempt to elicit a confession. The liars most commonly told relate to non-existent physical evidence, such as falsely claiming to have found a suspect's fingerprints or DNA at a crime scene. Detectives can also lie about having eyewitnesses or confessions from accomplices.
并评论道：“现在轮到他们付出代价了。”在接受盘问时，侦探皮纳和罗德里格斯在一个令人震惊的披露中承认伪造证据，以将胡安·卡塔兰牵连进玛莎·普埃布拉的谋杀案中。在美国，侦探在审讯嫌疑人时没有义务说实话，并被允许撒谎以试图诱供。最常见的谎言与不存在的物证有关，例如虚假声称在犯罪现场发现了嫌疑人的指纹或DNA。侦探还可以谎称有目击者或同伙的供词。
In Juan's case, detectives Pinar and Rodriguez admitted to doctoring the six-pack photographic lineups presented to Juan during his initial interrogation. The pair confessed that they were the ones who circled Juan's image and that they had forged the signature and words of a supposed witness that read, This is the guy who I saw doing the shooting. They justified their actions, calling the tactic a ruse to try to elicit a confession. Detectives Pinar and Rodriguez remained on the homicide squad throughout the long and drawn out civil suit. Martha Puebla's case technically remained open, but little was done to investigate as the police still believed in Juan's guilt. After three years, the civil suit finally reached
在胡安的案子里，侦探皮纳和罗德里格斯承认篡改了在最初审讯期间向胡安展示的六张照片辨认阵列。两人坦白是他们圈出了胡安的照片，并且伪造了据称是证人的签名和字迹，上面写着：“这就是我看到开枪的那个人。”他们为自己的行为辩护，称这种策略是为了诱供而使用的计谋。在漫长而拖沓的民事诉讼期间，侦探皮纳和罗德里格斯一直留在凶杀组。玛莎·普埃布拉的案件在技术上仍然悬而未决，但由于警方仍然相信胡安有罪，因此几乎没有采取什么调查行动。三年后，民事诉讼终于在
its conclusion in March 2007. The court found that the detectives had probable cause for arresting Juan and did acted in good faith when they tricked him into thinking witnesses had identified him as the killer through the doctored six-pack. Juan was awarded $320,000, an amount considered by some to be woefully inadequate. Although Juan could have continued to fight the city of Los Angeles for an improved outcome, he decided against appealing, as there was a possibility he could lose his compensation altogether. In January 2005, prosecutors began trial preparations for Vineland Boys gang member Jose Ledezma for the 2002 murders of Christian Vargas and Onrique Acosta. During this time, Spanish-speaking police officers were asked to listen to original
2007年3月迎来了结局。法院裁定，侦探们逮捕胡安有合理根据，并且在诱使他以为目击者通过被篡改的照片辨认出他是凶手时，主观上是出于善意。胡安获得了32万美元的赔偿金，一些人认为这个金额少得可怜。尽管胡安本可以继续与洛杉矶市抗争以获得更好的结果，但他决定不上诉，因为存在完全失去赔偿金的可能性。2005年1月，检方开始为“范地曼帮”成员何塞·莱德斯马准备审判，罪名是其涉嫌2002年谋杀克里斯蒂安·巴尔加斯和昂里克·阿科斯塔。在此期间，会说西班牙语的警察被要求收听
recordings of several telephone calls Ledezma had made from prison following his arrest. In late 2002, Ledezma called a man he referred to as Cokestar, asking, Do you know the slut that lives by my house? Her name starts with an M. I need her to disappear. She's dropping dimes. But keep a low profile, stay on your toes, homie, and don't get caught. Cokestar was a fellow Vineland Boys member named Javier Covarrubias. Covarrubias agreed to orchestrate the killing Ledezma had requested and persuaded two other gang members, Raul Robledo and Luis Sandoval, to assist. The men visited a firing range to test the gun they considered using to carry out the execution, but deemed it unacceptable and chose
莱德斯马被捕后从狱中打出的几个电话的原始录音。2002年底，莱德斯马打电话给一个他称为“Cokestar”的男子，问：“你知道住在我家附近的那个荡妇吗？她的名字以M开头。我需要她人间蒸发。她一直在告密。但要保持低调，机灵点，兄弟，别被抓到。”“Cokestar”是“范地曼帮”的另一名成员哈维尔·科瓦鲁比亚斯。科瓦鲁比亚斯同意策划莱德斯马要求的谋杀，并说服了另外两名帮派成员劳尔·罗夫雷多和路易斯·桑多瓦尔协助。这几个人去靶场测试了他们考虑用来执行处决的枪支，但认为不合格，转而选择了
a 9mm handgun instead. Police had been completely unaware that the order to kill Martha Puebla had been recorded months before her death. During their calls, Ledezma and Covarrubias had communicated in a mix of English and Spanish. At the time, authorities employed an external company to translate and transcribe their recordings twice, but they had done so poorly and their transcriptions were difficult to comprehend. It wasn't until over two years later when Spanish speaking officers listened to the raw audio of the calls themselves that their significance was fully realised. Not only did they implicate Ledezma and the Vineland Boys in Martha Puebla's murder, but they completely vindicated Juan Catalan, who wouldn't have been arrested and charged had
一把9毫米手枪。警方完全不知道谋杀玛莎·普埃布拉的命令在她死前数月就已经被录音了。在通话期间，莱德斯马和科瓦鲁比亚斯用英语和西班牙语夹杂着交流。当时，当局雇用了外部公司对录音进行两次翻译和转录，但他们的工作很糟糕，转录内容很难理解。直到两年多后，当会说西班牙语的警察亲自聆听通话的原始音频时，其重要性才被完全意识到。它们不仅将莱德斯马和“范地曼帮”牵连进玛莎·普埃布拉的谋杀案中，还彻底还了胡安·卡塔兰以清白，如果当时磁带
the tapes been heard properly in 2002. They also revealed that 18 days after Martha's murder, Ledezma phoned a different associate and used coded language to request that fellow gang member Carlos Casillas kill another teenage girl who was also acting as a police informant. While Jose Ledezma awaited trial, an 18-month investigation into the Vineland Boys came to an end. The inquiry stemmed from a 2003 incident in which a gang member shot and killed 26-year-old Burbank police officer Matthew Pavelka and seriously injured his partner Gregory Campbell. Matthew's murder prompted law enforcement to take action in dismantling the Vineland Boys. Task Force Operation Silent Night was created, consisting of 1,300 officers from various local
在2002年被正确聆听，他就不会被捕和起诉。他们还透露，在玛莎遇害18天后，莱德斯马给另一个同伙打电话，使用暗语要求帮派成员卡洛斯·卡西亚斯杀死另一名同样担任警方线人的十几岁女孩。在何塞·莱德斯马等待审判期间，历时18个月针对“范地曼帮”的调查宣告结束。该调查起因于2003年的一起事件，当时一名帮派成员开枪打死了26岁的伯班克警察马修·帕韦尔卡，并严重重伤了他的搭档格雷戈里·坎贝尔。马修的遇害促使执法部门采取行动瓦解“范地曼帮”。“静夜行动”专案组成立，由来自当地各部门的1300名警官组成
and federal departments and agencies. More than $1 million, 75 firearms, and 300 pounds of cocaine, heroin, and amphetamines were confiscated from the gang. 23 Vineland Boys members were arrested, with Jose Ledezma and Javier Coxtak of Arubias among those who were charged. The gang members faced a 56-count federal indictment for crimes committed over a 10-year period, including charges for racketeering and violating federal drug and weapon laws. Burbank police chief Thomas Hoefel told reporters, It is the ultimate affront to attack and kill those that protect others. The gang has terrorized people of Burbank for years. Today is Armageddon.
和联邦部门及机构。超过100万美元现金、75支枪械以及300磅可卡因、海洛因和苯丙胺被该帮派没收。23名“范地曼帮”成员被逮捕，何塞·莱德斯马和哈维尔·科瓦鲁比亚斯也在被起诉之列。这些帮派成员面临一项涵盖10年期间所犯罪行的56项罪名的联邦起诉，其中包括敲诈勒索以及违反联邦毒品和武器法的罪名。伯班克警察局长托马斯·霍费尔告诉记者：“攻击和杀害那些保护他人的人是对人类底线的最大挑衅。这个帮派多年来一直在伯班克恐怖统治。今天是世界末日。”
They will have Newturf to defend in the federal prison system. In January 2008, nearly five years after Martha Puebla's murder, Jose Ledezma struck a plea deal with the city of Los Angeles to avoid the death penalty. He confessed to the murders of Enrique Costa and Christian Vargas and admitted to soliciting the murders of both Martha Puebla and another teenage witness. Fellow Vineland Boys members Javier Covarrubias and Raul Robledo pleaded guilty to locating and killing Martha Puebla under Ledezma's instructions, with Robledo confessing to pulling the trigger. Ledezma, Covarrubias, and Robledo were reached sentenced to life in prison.
他们将在联邦监狱系统中拥有新的“地盘”来捍卫。2008年1月，在玛莎·普埃布拉遇害近五年后，何塞·莱德斯马与洛杉矶市达成认罪协议，以逃避死刑。他承认谋杀恩里克·科斯塔和克里斯蒂安·巴尔加斯，并承认教唆谋杀玛莎·普埃布拉以及另一名十几岁的证人。同为“范地曼帮”成员的哈维尔·科瓦鲁比亚斯和劳尔·罗夫雷多承认在莱德斯马的指示下找到并杀害了玛莎·普埃布拉，罗夫雷多承认自己扣动了扳机。莱德斯马、科瓦鲁比亚斯和罗夫雷多被判处终身监禁。
A fourth gang member, 22-year-old Luis Sandoval, who allegedly drove the men to Martha's home, was also charged. During the court proceedings, Martha's parents received assistance from a translator, and for the first time, they learned of the role the detectives Martin Pinner and Juan Rodriguez had played in their daughter's death. Just as they had done in their effort to elicit a confession from Juan Catalan, it was revealed that the detectives had also falsified the six-pack used during their interrogation of Jose Ledezma. Despite the obvious danger it presented to Martha Puebla, detectives Pinner and Rodriguez had circled Ledezma's photo and forged Martha's
第四名帮派成员、22岁的路易斯·桑多瓦尔据称开车将几人送到玛莎家，他也受到了指控。在法庭审理期间，玛莎的父母得到了翻译的协助，他们生平第一次知道了侦探马丁·皮纳和胡安·罗德里格斯在他们女儿之死中所起的作用。正如他们在试图从胡安·卡塔兰那里逼供时所做的那样，据透露，侦探们在审讯何塞·莱德斯马时也伪造了照片辨认阵列。尽管这给玛莎·普埃布拉带来了显而易见的危险，但侦探皮纳和罗德里格斯还是圈出了莱德斯马的照片并伪造了玛莎的
signature along with the message, this is who shocked my friend's boyfriend. Ledezma was convinced that the identification was genuine and that Martha was a police informant, but in reality, she had been so fearful of the violent boys that she'd protected Ledezma, refusing to offer any information to police or in court that might implicate him. The gang murdered Martha 11 days after she reluctantly testified at Ledezma's preliminary hearing. On May 13, 2008, Martha's parents filed a complaint against the city of Los Angeles, police chief William Bratton, and detectives Martin Pinner and Juan Rodriguez. They claimed that police had deliberately withheld information that Martha was being used as bait in their
签名以及这样一条信息：“这就是那个震惊我朋友男友的人。”莱德斯马确信辨认是真的，玛莎是警察的线人，但实际上，她对这些暴力团伙感到非常恐惧，以至于她一直在保护莱德斯马，拒绝向警方或在法庭上提供任何可能牵连他的信息。在这帮人强迫玛莎在莱德斯马的初审中勉强作证11天后，他们谋杀了她。2008年5月13日，玛莎的父母对洛杉矶市、警察局长威廉·布拉顿以及侦探马丁·皮纳和胡安·罗德里格斯提起了诉讼。他们声称警方故意隐瞒了玛莎在他们的调查中被当做诱饵的信息，
investigation and that her murder was a foreseeable result of their actions. The complaint's proceedings dragged out for two years, with a variety of lawyers working for Martha's parents on a no-win, no-fee basis. Police maintained to that Martha and her family had been offered protection, but had turned it down. One officer testified that he recalled hearing a discussion about the subject, but was unsure what came of it. Martha's parents denied this, which was backed by a detailed log the detectives kept of their investigation. It contained no record of them having contact with Martha's family after they showed the doctored six-pack to Ledezma. The family's lawyer told the court,
并且她的谋杀是他们行为可预见的结果。诉讼程序拖延了两年，多位律师以不赢官司不收费的方式为玛莎的父母工作。警方坚称曾向玛莎及其家人提供过保护，但被他们拒绝了。一名警官作证说，他记得听到过关于这个主题的讨论，但不确定结果如何。玛莎的父母对此予以否认，侦探们保存的详细调查日志也佐证了这一点。其中没有任何记录表明他们在向莱德斯马展示被篡改的照片后与玛莎的家人有过接触。一家的律师对法庭说：
Martha Puebla was murdered because the LAPD put a bullseye on her back by telling a gang member that she was a snitch. In return, the lawyer representing the city of Los Angeles and the LAPD claimed it was Martha's testimony at Ledezma's preliminary hearing that led to her murder. Even though Martha didn't accuse Ledezma in court, she had testified to other information, such as his gang affiliation, which would have been enough for the Vineland boys to seek retaliation. In April 2010, a jury found that detectives Pina and Rodriguez had acted negligently, maliciously, and recklessly, and had violated the due process rights of Martha and her parents. Their negligence was determined to be a substantial contributing factor in Martha's death,
玛莎·普埃布拉被谋杀是因为洛杉矶警察局在她的背上画了一个靶心，告诉一个帮派成员她是个告密者。作为回应，代表洛杉矶市和洛杉矶警察局的律师声称，正是玛莎在莱德斯马初审时的证词导致了她的谋杀。尽管玛莎在法庭上没有指控莱德斯马，但她作证了其他信息，例如他的帮派背景，这足以让范地曼帮寻求报复。2010年4月，陪审团裁定侦探皮纳和罗德里格斯行为疏忽、恶意且鲁莽，并侵犯了玛莎及其父母的正当程序权利。他们的疏忽被认定是导致玛莎死亡的一个实质性促成因素，
but the jury found that Martha and her parents had also acted negligently. They apportioned 20% of the responsibility for Martha's death to the detectives, and the remaining 80% to Martha and her parents. For the wrongful death of their daughter, Martha's parents were awarded a total of $1 in compensation. When Jose Ledezma's defense attorney was asked for her opinion on the deceptive tactics used by detectives to charge her client, she remarked, To the detectives, Martha Puebla didn't matter. She was just another reluctant witness. An anonymous Los Angeles public defender told the LA Weekly newspaper,
但陪审团发现玛莎和她的父母也有疏忽行为。他们将玛莎死亡20%的责任归咎于侦探，其余80%归咎于玛莎和她的父母。对于他们女儿的非正常死亡，玛莎的父母总共获得了1美元的赔偿。当被问及对侦探用来指控她当事人的欺骗性策略有何看法时，何塞·莱德斯马的辩护律师评论道：“对侦探来说，玛莎·普埃布拉根本不重要。她只是又一个不情愿的证人。”《洛杉矶周刊》采访的一位匿名的洛杉矶公设辩护人说，
and they wonder why people don't want to come forward. Neither detective was formally penalized for their conduct and both remained in the LAPD. Martin Pina was eventually reassigned to juvenile cases, while Juan Rodriguez was transferred to various departments, including the Vice Unit and Missing Persons Division, until his retirement in 2019. Lying to suspects to elicit a confession is still permitted in the United States, although the treatment of Martha Puebla and Juan Catalan has raised some concerns about the use of such tactics. In response to a feature article on the case published by the Los Angeles Times in July 2008, the LAPD announced they would be making
“难怪人们不愿意挺身而出。”两名侦探均未因其行为受到正式惩罚，且都留在了洛杉矶警察局。马丁·皮纳最终被重新调任处理少年案件，而胡安·罗德里格斯则被调到包括扫黑组和失踪人口科在内的各个部门，直至2019年退休。在美国，为了诱供而对嫌疑人撒谎仍然是被允许的，尽管对玛莎·普埃布拉和胡安·卡塔兰的对待引发了对使用此类策略的一些担忧。为了回应《洛杉矶时报》于2008年7月发表的一篇关于此案的深度报道，洛杉矶警察局宣布将做出
changes to their training. Detectives must now weigh the benefit of lying to a suspect against the potential danger the liars may create. They also have an obligation to offer police protection to anyone they believe they may have placed in danger. In February 2019, another raid on Los Angeles Street gangs resulted in the arrests of 27 members of the Vineland Boys. 54 firearms and nearly 4,000 grams of methamphetamine were seized and 45 members, including a number who were already incarcerated, were indicted for a range of crimes. Juan Catalan used his compensation payout to attend college and obtain an associate degree in general education and is currently working towards his bachelor's degree in business administration.
培训方面的更改。侦探现在必须权衡对嫌疑人撒谎的好处与谎言可能带来的潜在危险。他们也有义务向任何他们认为可能已置于危险之中人提供警方保护。2019年2月，对洛杉矶街头帮派的又一次突袭导致27名“范地曼帮”成员被捕。54支枪械和近4000克冰毒被缴获，45名成员（包括多名已经在押人员）因一系列罪名被起诉。胡安·卡塔兰用他的赔偿金上了大学，获得了普通教育副学士学位，目前正在攻读工商管理学士学位。
He visits underprivileged schools to speak to students about the importance of education and to assure them that their past circumstances and upbringing doesn't determine their future. He visits his older brother Mario in prison regularly and provides him with money to purchase permitted items such as candy and soda, but is determined never to see the inside of a prison cell ever again. Although Juan has not been able to speak to Martha Puebla's family, he acknowledges that they too are victims. In May 2019, he was interviewed by comedian Felipe Esparza for his podcast What's Up Full and stated, I feel for the family. They lost their daughter. They tried to sue the LAPD and they got one dollar.
他访问基础学校，向学生讲述教育的重要性，并向他们保证，过去的背景和成长环境并不能决定他们的未来。他定期去监狱探望哥哥马里奥，并给他钱买糖果和苏打水等允许的物品，但他决心再也不踏入监狱大门半步。尽管胡安无法与玛莎·普埃布拉的家人交谈，但他承认他们也是受害者。2019年5月，他接受了喜剧演员费利佩·埃斯帕萨的播客节目《What's Up Fool》的采访，并表示：“我对这家人感到难过。他们失去了女儿。他们试图起诉洛杉矶警察局，却只得到了一美元。”
One dollar. What sort of slap in the face is that? In 2017, media services provider and production company Netflix released the documentary about Juan's ordeal titled Longshot. Juan was reluctant to participate, but eventually agreed as a favor to his former attorney, Todd Melnick. The pair remain friends, often playing basketball and attending Lakers and Dodgers games together. In the documentary, Melnick, who Juan refers to as his white knight, said, We used all kinds of things, Hollywood TV shows, modern technology and good old-fashioned detective work to piece together things to determine where he was. Now here he is standing here, my friend.
一美元。那算是什么耳光？2017年，媒体服务提供商和制作公司网飞（Netflix）发布了一部关于胡安磨难的纪录片，名为《大冷门》（Longshot）。胡安起诉时不愿参与，但最终为了前律师托德·梅尔尼克的人情同意了。两人仍然是朋友，经常一起打篮球并参加湖人队和道奇队的比赛。在纪录片中，梅尔尼克（胡安称他为白马王子）说：“我们用了各种各样的方法，好莱坞电视节目、现代技术和古老传统的侦探工作来拼凑事情，以确定他在哪里。现在他站在了这里，我的朋友。”
Senior Vice President and General Counsel for the Dodgers, Sam Fernandez, posed the question, What if we hadn't done the deal with Larry David? What if the camera crew hadn't gone to that aisle on the field double? What if Juan's daughter had decided she didn't want to go to the ball game? What if he hadn't made the phone call? What if? What if? What if? Baseball remains an important part of Juan's life and when people ask why he is a fan of the Dodgers, he tells them, For one thing, they saved my life. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
道奇队高级副总裁兼总法律顾问萨姆·费尔南德斯提出了这样一个问题：“如果我们没有和拉里·戴维达成协议会怎么样？如果摄像机组没有去场边双打的那个过道会怎么样？如果胡安的女儿决定不想去看球赛会怎么样？如果他没有打那个电话会怎么样？如果？如果？如果？”棒球仍然是胡安生活的重要部分，当人们问他为什么是道奇队的球迷时，他告诉他们：“一方面，他们救了我的命。”该剧集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。